you're watching the game spot co-op
stage sponsored by lego star wars the
force awakens what's up guys welcome
back to the kind of funny cross gamespot
III 2016 stage I'm Jim Gettys that's
Greg Miller right here big tourney yeah
10 we made Kearney now make I'm really
excited to have you here this was
totally planned yeah holy planet even
saw you and grabbed you yeah I want to
know I do that all the time okay what
are your your biggest moments of e3
what's your favorite thing so far the
number one thing that I've seen that
I've been most excited about is we happy
few you came out of nowhere what a cruel
good such a great trailer I'm excited I
love the 1984 brave new world sort of
Bioshock e black glove feel I love it
i'm very excited i really like the
microsoft's kind of getting a lot of
focus to games like that and their
conferences because old microsoft
totally would not have done that's all
gears of war halo whatever but here's a
smaller title it's a little more like
art scene difference i'll definitely
that look gave it a chance to breathe I
seen it it packs a couple months ago in
a really you got dropped into a thing
and I'm like I don't know what's
happening I have no idea what this world
is but that trailer alone set it up of
like oh oh this is something real
something's very twisted here
something's very wrong I really enjoyed
it i also got inside although they were
like all right guys best game i've ever
played and we're not gonna show it to
you it's coming out later this month
it's like hope you enjoyed the challenge
exactly and the trailer by the way with
somebody like a copy of it yeah exactly
don't worry i'm really excited but it's
limbo right it's how that agrees you
know they could have just been like
we've debited it from your account i
have been like fair enough ya know sony
press conference what are you thoughts
oh very good i thought of course kojima
knows how to make an entrance yes i love
it um i love that they already have a
consumer productions already has a title
to announce so cool is it BTW part two
cuz it's basically norman reedus is
gonna be inspired you know I definitely
don't think it's gonna be quite as
horror I think it's gonna be a bit a bit
more sci-fi horror as opposed to like
psychological horror I was hoping this
is why Allison road was cancelled and
they were like cuz they cancelled red
like we're gonna tell you in a few days
I was hoping this was the few days oh my
god I got hired by negima production apt
yeah yeah and no gilma del Toro to be
found I know I kept waiting for I kept
waiting for that final thing of people
on there no yeah now there what was your
biggest surprise biggest surprise okay
it's not a surprise in a game but might
the biggest surprise so far any press
conference how much people don't care
about Skylanders like they're like crash
bandicoot we were like yeah and he's
like let's take a look at Skyliners and
were like oh but here's the thing okay
why don't you tell me that there is the
thing the thing i love the Bandicoot ah
static you near and dear to this man's
heart so they were playing with my
emotions a lot there I got their press
conference I've been waiting for some
crash bandicoot for years right so
finally I hear that music kick in I lose
my [ __ ] and we've heard the rumors of
the skylanders and I was like I don't
want this please please not like this
not like this then we said octa vision
else like oh they're doing it but then
he was like we're remastering crash one
two three you crash here's the thing you
this is the steps to New crash we need
to realize this you need to support this
you need to buy crash 1 2 & 3 remastered
when it happens then don't make a new
crush then actually ignore the Bambino
stage the bed acute this is happening
down with Scylla oh well the skyliners
that's a that's a hole they go to
mitch's what's up yeah we need fitted no
no too soon too soon I'm also very
excited um the tell-tale trailer yo the
teaser yeah Clementine that they told us
we weren't gonna get that we were gonna
like check in on her but there wasn't
gonna be she wasn't gonna be the focus
so this trailer makes me think they were
lying or maybe that the dude she's with
is gonna be the focus that's not what I
want give me that Clem Clem I want to
add him on earlier oh yeah he is almost
I fully I must capture crap haha braver
great no the idea is that you're both
playable both are playable that guy in
summer place and be Clem the whole time
no I doubt it I'm gonna [ __ ] they were
talking Jill was talking about it being
like tales from the borderlands
hopping around playing in good thing and
I asked are gonna be more characters
than just those two he would neither
confirm nor deny yes yeah alright so my
last question for you here have you
played zelda have you seen Zelda what do
you know about Zelda I don't know
anything tell me let me tell you what I
know about Zelda is I was going over
there and now I'm here sorry I just made
the mistake of saying hello before I cut
some place yeah okay well you can go you
can go play zelda now make tourney thank
you very much for joining us you can
find her over roosterteeth the know
twitter.com / meg turney every social
thing / meg turney do it stay right here
what purple crippled through yahoo we're
all coordinated yeah I'm liking that we
looking damn good you want to keep
seeing this look damn good stay right
here on gamespot com flash the first
thing you you posted I'm not sure
anymore without me calm or kind of work
out of funny this why do you let me do
this yeah I don't know magic interview
seemed really good no it's me it was
alright at best I love you all you're
watching the game spot co-op stage
sponsored by lego star wars the force
awakens